she loves a good you know ring kris
jenner weighs in on those khloe
kardashian engagement rumors
and opens up about kim kardashian's life
after divorce
kim's good she's good i don't know how
she
does it tune in because you never know
what's going to happen
the famous momager gives an update on
her daughters and their recent life
changes on thursday's episode of the
ellen degeneres show
chris and ellen first discuss coco's
plans to expand her family
it's such a blessing we have all this
modern science and technology and
everything we have available to us but
it's still been a really strange
way to go about it earlier this month
chloe revealed that she and her
boyfriend tristan thompson have made
embryos
i mean i think it's so great that they
want to
do that again and have a sibling for
true because there's nothing better than
a big family and
brothers and sisters and that's just my
heart
so i'm really happy i just want them to
be happy and true will be so excited
and will the other kid be named false
that's a good one as for the recent
engagement rumors sparked by
this instagram pic isn't that crazy
chris played koi
that's a good ring i think she just
loves jewelry
mm-hmm she's a she she loves a good
you know ring yeah yeah if you should
ask chloe
okay so no real answer on that one but
she did reveal how her second oldest
daughter kim kardashian is doing after
filing for divorce from kanye west
last month kim's good she's good she's
really
really
busy working on all of her different
projects that she's doing and i don't
know how
she does it with all those grandbabies
she's she's got a lot of energy that kid
and according to chris the kkw beauty
founder's passion for law
is keeping her busy amid her split
you know she's so focused and she's so
like she's just passionate about the
whole thing
and everything she stands for and i see
her
studying whenever she has it's in her
schedule
every single day when i get all the
schedules for the kids it's her study
time
is all blocked out so nothing nothing
else can get in the way so i really i'm
so proud of her
you know having her dad do what he did
she always looked up to her dad and
that was her idol chris also recently
sat down with the wall street journal
magazine
and dished on the person living or dead
she'd most like to have dinner with
probably robert kardashian
or jesus is the top my top top top
but the two of them at the same dinner
would be even better
it's never a dull moment the 20th and
final season of the family's hit reality
show premiered
last week and chris opened up about what
she's going to miss
most quote our crew was with us from day
one
season 1 episode 1. it was almost 14 and
a half years of filming with the same
people
we're going to really miss them